[Music]
christian and i were lucky enough to
grow up in a neighborhood full of kids
we lived right next to a dead end there
were parents there too wasn't oh yeah it
wasn't like lord of the flies
yeah it wasn't a free-for-all we were
not on deserted islands and there was a
conch shell and whoever had the conch
shell had the power we get it you read
lord of the flies
and piggy broke his glasses but anyway
yeah we grew up around a lot of kids and
shout outs to the callahan's the
chandlers we talk about the burlington
oh the whole gang um the ellis's my
friend clay ella's the best oh so we
were right next to a little cul-de-sac
but i remember getting when we got our
bikes when we got like dirt bikes that
could go
outside that safety zone of like however
many streets just to like a couple
streets we would test the boundaries of
that zone you know you'd like just go
like one street a little and that one
new street was like dangerous and like
forbidden territory and i mean it's
really funny to think about now because
um
of how much we've gotten to travel but
uh so our wonder years yeah or are um
kind of like goonies but without a very
intense adventure we had adventures but
that's why i think goonies was so great
it's like a tame goonies yeah but we
were goony we were like you know all got
along like the goonies and so let's talk
about the goonies well here we go
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
you're listening to life for short i'm
your host justin long life could be a
dream
[Music]
and with me as always is
closed
uh and my brother who's plucking he's
stroking his mustache
stroking yes and you're thinking ah you
forgot how to do the show it's been a
little it's been a minute yeah i've been
traveling uh speaking of adventures i've
been having adult adventures oh no
i think that sounds like i was having
like orgies i was traveling around the
world doing
having different orgies but um you're an
adult and you've had adventures i know i
uh but not adult adventures that's true
all right you're having adventures
is it funny that that word adult when
you add it to things it is weird it
becomes like sexual it's completely yeah
it's been co-opted i know you can't say
adult something without its sounding
sexuality the adult film industry that's
just the film i'm having an adult dinner
tonight
you are i'm having a dinner i'm an adult
who happens to be having dinner with
other adults yeah but it's not sexual i
know but it's but it doesn't sound
sexual i'm having an adult dinner it
sounds erotic so you're going to eat
like you know yeah
okay certain types of burgers and tacos
burgers why are we talking about um
adventures adventures and the innocence
of our youth and you uh mentioned
goonies right yeah i did because um that
movie comes up a lot when i think about
my own childhood and i think that's why
it was such a huge movie for us because
it was like it was so well directed and
acted it was so realistic that the whole
beginning of that movie was kind of like
what we were experiencing in that
cul-de-sac neighborhood that we grew up
in but they just went obviously further
and they went in search of the you know
the ultimate childhood adventure like
the pirate treasure and all that we're
talking about that because our guest
today was the star of not only the
goonies but another seminal
movie of our childhood stand by me which
is similarly the kids go on an adventure
and as well as many great formative who
is it who is it who is that i'll tell
you in a second just let's just be
honest a little patience corey feldman
what it's corey feldman our guest is so
exciting yes the corey feldman who um
yeah we grew up watching i mean we grew
up in those movie gremlins friday the
13th he was in classics of the 80s and
um lost boys oh yeah of course i mean
somebody that i've been aware of since i
was a little kid and so uh just
similarly to
fred savage it was really surreal and
exciting to get to talk to him have you
met him before i had never met him um a
friend of the show very best friend of
the show gerry oh best friend of the
show is uh obviously very close with him
and and they've stayed in touch and and
so when i hear about him it's through
jerry um but no i've
never met him until now well i go like
let's listen should i give a little
disclaimer about the recording oh yeah
good idea um we did a this was slightly
frustrating uh we did a long recording
with corey about i would say an hour and
a half
and then he um
realized that he hadn't been recording
so it was a chat it was a long talk
which i would have enjoyed anyway
um but it's sort of like the podcast
version of if a tree falls in the forest
and
no one's around to here it's like the
kevin smith experience exactly what
happens with what happened with him
although i yeah kevin
might be a different situation slightly
different yes but in both cases it
must have been
monumentally frustrating for you when
you discovered that it hadn't been
recording though it wasn't as long as
the kevin won that one was
still an hour and a half and it's
you know yeah that's
a long time that must have been hard for
you i remember once you uh
you wrote eight pages of a sitcom and
your computer erased it and i thought
you were going to throw yourself through
the wall you were so upset yeah that was
before meditation this must have been
frustrating yeah before meditation
before i be i learned how to breathe and
uh begin again and just accept things
but anyway so we do reference some
things that we talked about in the first
around in the i guess the practice round
uh and
he does a very funny recap of it so if
there's anything i can think of that we
missed
in the interview uh we can talk about it
in the outro okay so here we go the
legendary um
just a huge part of our childhoods and
probably all of yours
corey feldman life could be a dream
[Music]
so from this point forward we will not
have to stop again
because this uh this phone is fully
charged and ready to rock so we should
have at least a good hour on here okay
great and the bad news is i'm not a
technical genius and uh did not record
record the first half so sadly we're
gonna have to repeat the entire first
half of the show luckily my photographic
memory will come into play so i'm going
to repeat everything from the start
starting now okay so uh basically you
started off by asking me about jerry
o'connell and then yeah we talked about
how jerry was a great guy and what a
wonderful friend and he said yeah he
says really nice things about you too
and i was like he's such a wonderful guy
so charming and he's rebecca rebecca
romain is his wife and how lucky he
talks about his good looks his
aesthetically how pleasing is yep right
and then we talked about how you know
stand by me was very uh profound and
avoid those emotions that we had to
evoke yes and what about me being abused
as a kid oh my god it was terrible and
my dad and
geez how did i say it from that i mean
we could keep going all day no no no we
got actually that was a perfect recap i
i preferred it the second time because
the first time there's so many details
there were so many like kind of like
heart-wrenching and heart-warming
details and humor that you provided
right you don't need anything you don't
need any of the first step right yes i
just want the bullet points
yeah
that's what makes a good story right of
course that but the rest is just fodder
anyway who cares about that superfluous
bs i think there's a way now to make to
take advantage of what happened because
um
there are things because now we're going
to do the real interview now we're going
to do that real interview does this one
now i'm going to try that's right i'm
going to be present now but before i was
just frankly i was just scrolling
through my phone you were winging it you
were winging it yeah you were basically
calling it
you were all just white noise um
you were born in reseda california do
you have any siblings i do have many
siblings actually wow i have two
brothers and two sisters oh oh where are
you in the line we're like the brady
bunch i'm right in the middle uh well
not right in the middle i'm the second
oldest second eldest if you will my
older sister mindy started this whole
shebang of being part of hollywood by
being the first out there to become
famous uh my father was actually you
know my father started in rock bands and
stuff so he was already kind of getting
the groupies and the fans and stuff but
my sister was the real superstar she
was a original member of the mickey
mouse club oh no
not the original mickey mouse club but
the second second wave of mickey mouse
club which was in the 70s you know
before before our time but you know
there was a group before britney and
justin on all of them that was not the
original group which is the black and
white annette funicello and all those
but there was a middle one and that
middle one was in the 70s and my sister
was one of those what type of kid were
you were you also like a very gregarious
kid were you prone to performing
yes yes of course i mean i was always
dressing up in costumes and running
around you know
playing 15 different characters and
acting it all out and i'd be the bad guy
fighting batman and i'd be robin too and
then i'd switch you know a cape and
become batgirl you know i mean did you
do that with your siblings a lot or were
you off on your own you know i was i was
older so i didn't really have a chance
he would by the time my my young
brothers were old enough to play with
you know i'm like 10 10 12
so you know dealing with all the abuse
that i was dealing with and still
working non-stop it was very hard to
kind of get into play mode but i would
have sometimes like i would play with
the kids and i remember one game we used
to play which i loved is i would play
radio dj and i would set up this little
tent in their room and i would uh have a
little speaker that went out you know
outside the tent and i had a little tape
recorder inside the tent yeah my phone
yes i would take requests and i'd play
you know hey it's a kcor corey feldman
show you're listening to kcor and uh
we've got a request today from our young
brother eden it looks like he really
wants to rock out with van halen you
know i think we can accommodate that
that's really funny that we're gonna do
our top ten today the top ten list of uh
everything i wanna hear and here it is
so you would entertain them they were
like they they must have did they have
that instinct did they were they um
like that were they outgoing like that
or did you do enough for the whole
family yeah they were very outgoing but
not i mean look she she cycled us
through my mom you know it was like a
you know actor puppy though oh
that's right absolutely yeah you have to
go to school like all the other cows
that's funny and all the other sacred
cows we also talked about vegetarian
there's so much we talked about it's a
bummer but um
i'm glad that we have a little bit more
time because you're you're so
interesting cory and the way you mention
the abuse
is
you're kind of it's almost off the cuff
you you it it seems like something
you've really like processed talked
about 3 000 times yes yeah yeah
and i and i certainly don't want to
dwell on it but i'm i'm curious uh you
mentioned that 10 or 11 uh it was
something that you were dealing with
were your siblings as well did that is
that something
it was a very abusive household but i
got the brunt of it because i was the
oldest boy right uh so you know my
sister had a way of kind of
you know being manipulative and kind of
working her way under you know my mom's
kind of
right hand man sort of echelon you know
what i mean so she kind of got that
position of like i'm i'm your i'm your
apprentice i kind of will go along with
your plans and and tell on my brother
when he does things so that way he's the
one that gets in trouble instead of me
and you know that kind of stuff is it
hard to have compassion for or easy
knowing that you kind of went through
the same thing and she was just doing it
for survival well no now we're we're
very close actually okay his sister and
i get along very well we're probably i'm
probably closer to her than anybody else
in my family to be honest um so yeah we
definitely share that kind of brothers
and sisters in arms thing now looking
back on it uh but of course at the time
you know she was scared for herself too
so she did what made sense logically for
her which was to you know best protect
herself so it's hard to be really noble
and stand up was it and did well she
wanted to just she would she wanted to
be the teacher's pet kind of thing yeah
totally and and and my mom you know
placated that yeah but not all the time
i mean she's still got i mean you know
my mom would do things like like you
know coming in the middle of the night
and and see that you had like a shirt
laying on the ground and a pair of
shorts laying on the ground and then she
would take all of your stuff out of the
drawers and throw it everywhere and rip
all your stuff out of the closet and
wake you up and say now clean your room
you know and this would be like 3 30 in
the morning and you'd have to clean your
room until you could go back to sleep to
get an hour of sleep before school oh so
so like real emotional abuse yeah yeah
yeah you know and like she would make us
watch mommy dearest i don't know if you
ever saw that movie yeah
but she thought it was a comedy
and um
she would sit there and laugh and she
would say see you guys got nothing see
you guys don't have it so bad you think
you've got it so bad at least i'm not
hitting you with wire hangers oh my god
did you ever have a moment where you
were able to forgive her or reconcile
with her in any way um she's not
mentally well yeah yeah you know so the
thing is is that
we can forgive but if somebody doesn't
get to that point of recovery for
themselves they're they're never gonna
change so we can't expect change because
that's very unhealthy if we go down that
road you know expecting different
results it's insanity right so we can't
expect that so all we can expect is that
we can do our best to let go of these
painful memories and these emotions and
we can forgive you know with the
understanding that like when somebody's
not mentally
all there you can't hate them for the
fact that they're not all there so i
don't have any anger towards her i don't
have any hate towards her i just don't
have any compassion either you know so
the problem is is i just you know i i
had to remove myself from the situation
and and it wasn't like
just you know she abused me as a kid so
i just stopped talking to her i
literally tried to keep my parents in my
life for most of my life until about 10
years ago and it was right around the
release of my book
that was the final straw when i wrote
choreography and i presented my mother a
tablet with the entire book on it and i
said here mom i want you to read this
and and let me know if you have any
problems because the book will be out in
about six months this is a final draft
but we can still make
edits and notes and changes and if
there's anything that you have a real
problem with i'm open to talking about
it and discussing it did you anticipate
was it was there a part of that that
felt um
was that first of all was i'm sure
writing the book was therapeutic but
very cathartic i'm sure
and but then offering your mother an
opportunity to address some of that
stuff was that uh was that something
that you struggled with did a
professional advise that no no no i
wanted it i mean i thought this would be
a good healing process for us and and
and at the time we had been spending
more time and we were kind of you know
talking and you know and here's the
thing i would bring events up to her and
i would say you know she'd say well why
do you why are you so angry with me why
do you look at me like you can't say i
have nothing but love for you i don't
understand i'd say mom used to hold me
down on the ground and torture me
sticking sharp knives in my eyeballs you
know and telling me you were gonna cut
my face open or you know
hitting me over the head with these
giant objects like like toilet seat lids
or you know just just crazy things that
she did did she not remember that you
think none of it none of them haven't
been none of it and she's oh that must
have been really difficult jesus
threatened to kill me on a pretty
regular basis and tell me i was gonna
die i mean you know really horrific yeah
yeah dramatic stuff for a kid yeah i ran
away once to the police and the police
turned me back to her because she
convinced them that i was just a good
actor
and oh was and she was smart enough to
never bruise me
you know she would hit me in ways that
there was no bruising well
psychologically
pulling the hair you know just things
that you know you know aren't going to
leave a bruise and she was very good at
that because i had to be on camera all
the time
probably the meal ticket well absolutely
yeah yeah
so anyway so being the oldest boy what
happened was
my sister eventually moved out and went
to college and when she moved out went
to college then it was all on me
right so it was me and then not only
that but my mom liked to sleep till like
three in the afternoon i would be like
you had to take care of your siblings
yeah exactly i had to take care of my
siblings i had to be the one that cooked
them breakfast i had to you know do
their diapers i had i mean everything i
i was a dad i was a dad at you know
eight years old really holy because my
my dad left after
the second
boy was born so it was me and then after
me it was eight years in between and
then my brother eden was born and then a
year later my brother devin was born and
my dad split the night that my brother
was born he never even came to the
hospital for the second kid being born
and at that point i'm not i'm nine and a
half i'm 10 years old so at that point i
became dad and i literally had to do all
the dad responsibilities from feeding
the kids to diapering the kids to
bathing the kids to you know getting
them to bed so he left and then i'm
raising these two kids and so i become
the one that takes a lot of the abuse
and then
around 13 i went to go do stand by me
and
i kind of reconciled with my father a
little bit
and then by lost boys
things grew so far out of control
because my mom was partying and she was
out of her mind and wasn't being a mom
and i ended up getting fired on the lost
boys set a lot of people don't know this
but i was actually fired by joel
schumacher because my mom had been out
on a binge all night and i was you know
up all night looking for her
and i didn't know what to do
and then i actually ended up doing drugs
for the first time accidentally on that
set because there was a woman who said
oh i you know i did it with your mom
this is what she does to stay up because
we're shooting these night shoots you
know and and you can just do this and
stay up with me and it's like your mom
and i was like okay so i tried cocaine i
tried cocaine for the first time
and uh and i and i had done like one
line and i thought that would last me
you know for 24 hours or something so i
stayed up all night all morning
and then i go to set i go to the set at
five o'clock the next day and i'm brain
dead because i hadn't slept you know but
i got it do you remember what you were
shooting that decor because i remember
that yeah the comic book scene yes
the main scene the main truth justice in
the american way that speech yes that
was the day
oh my god
what a huge day what an awful day for
that to happen
right
so
so uh yeah so i mean i you know he's
telling me all this direction you know
take two two two steps you know and then
you're gonna stop and then the camera is
gonna rack you're gonna say the first
part of your line and then you're gonna
go around
the the the uh comic book stand you know
there was like this circular yeah you're
gonna go around to the other side of it
you're going to pull the comic book out
and then you're going to deliver your
next line over the shoulder you know and
i'm going like okay wait pull out the
shoulder uh
you haven't slept you haven't slept
right right and i was just i kept
messing up over and over and over and
joel just was lit he was like what the
hell is wrong with you what the hell is
wrong with you
where are you today why are you not here
are you on drugs and i was like i wish i
was on drugs
poor kid and you're a kid i mean like
that's funny i i to me you were i forget
that because it's hard to i was just
talking to a friend of mine about this
when you when you know somebody so well
from childhood and you see them over the
course of i don't know once every 10
years and but to you they're still that
kid you know they're they're
they still have that look like yeah and
i was a kid i mean i was very much a kid
so to me i was gonna say corey you were
like two or three years a couple years
older than me so to me you were like in
an adult like old like an old cool like
teenager when i was a kid but but yeah
but in reality i was very reality oh
amazing that's crazy so so what happened
was uh he fired me and then you know
basically they were like well we need
you know this mom isn't gonna work the
mom is not a parent and then you know i
explained to joel what happened i just
told him everything and then
after that day well he fired me before
he knew what was going on yeah he was
just like you're you're out of it you're
you know i'm not gonna work with you
like this this is ridiculous so he says
well you know i can't have this we need
a real guardian on the set with you
who's gonna actually you know watch what
you're doing so we called my dad to see
if my dad could do it
and my dad said well i'm not available
now but i'll be available in a couple
weeks
so i guess we worked it out so that when
we got back to la i would move him with
my dad for a while and he would now take
over as my guardian
well on the interim
they still had to get somebody up to
santa cruz to to to be my chaperone set
guy whatever so who do we call but marty
weiss and marty weiss was somebody that
my mom knew because he would pick me up
and take me to these saturn award things
and he was always kind of around and you
know
trying to be part of our life trying to
yeah it's weird and so she made this
really healthy at first she was very
against him and she said oh you know i
don't like this guy he creeps me out but
eventually after you know he had come
and kidnapped me a few times he
literally kidnapped me because he would
talk me into leaving in the middle of
the afternoon without my mom knowing
about it and i would go and i would meet
him in a particular place and
he would take me in his car and take me
to the mall or take me to different
places because i was like a prisoner and
i wasn't allowed to leave ever you know
i couldn't just go to my friend's house
yeah i couldn't like go to my friend's
house for the day or i couldn't you know
go do a sleepover or things like that so
to me
the only way i was allowed to leave the
house is if i told my mom i was jogging
because she always told me that i was
fat and so the only
the only regimen that i was able to
follow was i could you know not eat
during the day and the only way i could
leave the house is if i went out for
exercise because i was a fat kid and i
needed to lose weight so she would let
me go jog so i'd say okay mom i'm going
out for a jog i'd call marty weiss and
he would come and pick me up and take me
out to the mall for an hour and then i'd
come back and throw some water on my
face and be like oh it was a good run
today mom that's crazy when was this how
did you meet this guy in the first place
like your mom was aware of him he
contacted us
and started calling us saying you know
hey i represent the saturn awards uh
which is like a sci-fi for sci-fi horror
stuff right yeah and we want to present
you with an award for your work in
gremlins
and we never got through the steven
spielberg story no no let's get back we
have to go back to that but let's go
back
i'll finish this real quick so so uh
what happened was uh she didn't like him
at first she knew he was kind of creepy
you know she had the mother sense or
whatever
and so at first she kept me away from
him but then
he ended up schmoozing her to the point
of where they ended up partnering
together and having like a management
company together for like a year or two
and so at that point he you know built a
trust with her and she goes yeah let's
call him up and have him be the guy to
watch you on the set and literally you
know within five minutes of him arriving
he's molesting my best friend so it was
oh my god yeah yeah yeah did you ever
tell her that like is that one of those
things when you then attempted to you
sent her the book i want to get back to
that when you sent her the book and she
was like what do you talk like
you know i don't remember doing any of
this to you i don't remember right so
she so when we had to add those talks
building up to that and i would say you
know mom you know there was this marty
was a scumbag
yeah well not even about marty i mean
we're talking about you know that that
stuff i didn't even really just like
home life stuff yeah just like why would
you abuse me like this or how could you
do this to me or you know how could you
how could you bash my head into the wall
you know things like that
you know and she would say no that never
happened that never happened and i would
say yo no mom it did happen and i would
give her like specific details and she'd
be like oh no no that never happened you
know i could never do that to my
children i love my children so she's
just in this complete land of denial so
i knew that it was going to be a problem
i knew that we would have conflict when
i wrote the book because i knew she
wouldn't remember it or she would say
she didn't remember it so i basically
said to her listen here's the deal
you don't have to agree with what i
write
in fact i expect you not to
but i'm open to talking about them and
if there's really anything that i'm
misprinting or saying wrong i will fix
it
and what i ask is that you go through
the book
and give me your notes and tell me what
you have issues with and then i'll go
and try and you know look at them but
that said
in the end when this book comes out
there's three approaches you can take
approach one
would be to say hey this is great
because the press will come to you right
the press will come to you so when the
press comes to you there's three ways
you can approach it a you say back to
them hey this is great i'm really proud
of my son you know i think he's done a
great thing this is very cathartic and
i'm i'm really glad that he's getting
through this this tough time in his life
by by expressing it and getting it out
there for other people to learn from and
i support them 100
that's one approach
approach b
would be you don't agree with the things
that i'm saying and you say hey listen
you know i'm proud of my son i love my
son unfortunately there's some things we
still don't see eye to eye on and i
might not agree with everything that's
in the book but i do support him and i
do love him well approach b
approach b c could also be
um
that that could have been dealt with
prior to the press coming i mean you're
giving her the opportunity to address
a potential approach right yeah but i'm
still giving her the openness of like
hey and even if after we've worked out
whatever we work out if you still feel
that it doesn't agree with you okay okay
you have the right to say it just say it
in a respectful way so it's like hey
there's things i disagree with but i
still support my son and i still love
him and i'm proud of him yeah that's it
and a story or c
the worst of all possible options is
that you say oh you know he's just lying
or oh he's just making it up or whatever
and you try to deny it
number one if you try to deny it and
diminish what i'm saying
you you will be the bad guy
nobody is going to look at you and say
oh you're a good mom and he's just
making all this stuff you know so
she took c
yeah exactly exactly i said whatever you
do don't do that you know yeah yeah the
one thing and if you do it then i'm not
gonna ever be able to talk to you again
like and this is kind of your last
chance yeah i've done this 100 times
with you and all i'm asking for is
support i'm not asking you to lie i'm
not asking you to
go against your own
personal values or beliefs or whatever
corey i wonder i mean first of all i
think it's really generous that you gave
her that opportunity i think it's also
really brave that you set those
boundaries and that you
that you held fast to those boundaries
because that's not easy to do i know in
my own life it's um
you know it's tough
[Music]
we talk about viori a lot on the show um
i wear my viori all the time i got a lot
of frankly a lot of compliments on it
and you know how much i love compliments
viori is built to move and sweat in yet
it's designed with a west coast
aesthetic that transitions effortlessly
into everyday life now what does that
mean that means uh you can wear it
anywhere the grocery store the club
i have not been to the club in a while
but i would definitely wear my viewery
sweats there i wear them everywhere they
feel great they look great you can't go
wrong breaking down the boundaries of
traditional activewear they're a new
perspective on performance apparel
vyori's mission is to create quality
products without extra waste i should
have led with this they offset 100 of
their carbon footprint
and um i i did like i said i really love
mine i have sweatpants that i put on
ostensibly to go to the gym and
but i end up
oftentimes not going to the gym and just
feeling so great and relaxed i have the
men's performance jogger on the days
where i do go jogging uh it's great and
it feels great you can really move in it
sometimes i put the jogger on and i just
lounge so get 20 off your first purchase
at fiori.com
long that's fiore spelled v
u o r i dot com slash long for 20 off
last night i came back from a little
vacation and um if you've traveled
internationally as i was lucky enough to
do you know that when you come home
come back to your time zone it can take
a second to kind of readjust to the to
the times i know these are
very privileged problems to have but um
they are problems technically so if you
were like me
last night and want to help readjust to
a different time zone try plus cbd
uh it can help it helped me last night
daily use of plus cbd sleep gummies get
you the rest that you need so you can
wake up feeling focused and refreshed
like i am right now uh this is the
result of a full night of sleep thank
you
plus cbd gummies they're formulated by a
team of medical experts and doctors plus
cbd sleep gummies taste great they do i
can definitely attest to that and
they're made with award-winning cbd
combined with melatonin magnolia bark
one of my favorite barks and lemon balm
also one of my favorite balms sleep
better tonight by visiting
pluscbdoil.com
and enter promo code long
for 40
off your order that's code long at plus
cbd oil.com for 40 off
hello hello
[Music]
so spielberg is somebody that you had
you said prior to gremlins
uh you you knew you got to know
yourself here's how it happened
so uh i auditioned originally for e.t
oh
so not before the part of e.t
no yes i originally was using
don't i do that real yeah it was a real
character actor it was amazing that i
got it i mean you know he's like you
might need to you know pull your head
out a little bit of your ass because you
were it wasn't retractable we need a
little bit more of a cone-shaped look
it's a physical thing maybe maybe you
could stretch out your eyes a little bit
yeah no but but no uh it was originally
the script was written as
a story about a boy and his best friend
who discovered an alien yeah huh that
was the original script for eg and it
was called uh i believe watch the skies
watching the skies watcher of the skies
something like that
and um that's much better than e.t yeah
right
i wish they had gone with that but right
why didn't they you know just imagine
the watcher of this guy
um but anyway so
i went down to mgm studios
and i met with steven spielberg when he
had a little rinky dink office there on
the lot at mgm and he had two posters up
on the wall one was raiders of the lost
ark and the other one was jaws
and uh and that was his legacy you know
that's he had 1941 oh yeah there was
nineteen forty-one jobs encounters yeah
no uh yeah yeah yeah closing counters
was already out but i don't he didn't
have that poster for whatever reason it
was that the three posters were 1941
jaws and raiders of the last arc and now
to contextualize it you know this cory
but i'm telling the audience he has like
obviously a palatial like a wing like
amblin
entertainment it's a huge part of the
universe a lot right yeah which which
actually was developed and built while
we were friends so i got this
you know so cool from from nothing so so
when i first met with him though yeah he
just had a tiny little office on the on
the mgm lot
and
i went over and i read for him
and we hit it off so well that he kind
of like threw his arm around my shoulder
and said you got some time you want to
walk around i was like sure
and that was it like we became buds and
he took me around and he said i'm
working on this movie right now and at
the time i thought he was the director
but i i came to realize later that he
was not the director he was just kind of
like he did with goonies he was a very
hands-on executive producer that's what
i heard i in fact i i was going to ask
you about uh sorry to interrupt but i
because i heard stories about
poltergeist how he was very hands-on in
fact like a lot of people say he
directed the maturity exactly yeah
exactly from my perspective he was the
director you mean of of poltergeist or
yes of poltergeist yeah so that's where
so that so that's what he was shooting
so he takes me down to the set of
poltergeists okay and we walk onto the
set and it happens to be the day that
they're turning the whole set upside
down and the kids are flying
uh through the room you know what i'm
talking about where they're like out the
window in the tree and all that stuff oh
yeah totally holding on to the tree yeah
right yeah like the the big epic you
know yeah moment from that movie and
that just happens to be this the scene
they're shooting the day that i met
stephen so were they shooting that on
the lot cory they were shooting it on
the on the mgm lot on the sound wow
so they had the entire bedroom on this
kind of gurney thing it was like a
rotating
shell and they literally had to crank it
and they cranked the entire set and the
entire set turned upside down and all
the kids were strapped into safety belts
and they were literally hanging in the
air and so was joe beth williams so joe
beth and the kids are all high you know
flying around
and
the room is upside down so the window is
up here and the floor is you know down
here the wall is down here and the floor
is on the side so there's some they're
they're like quintessential spielberg
shots in that movie they're such great
shots and and that's uh correct me if
i'm wrong that's probably something that
wouldn't happen today i mean aside from
the whole
they would use cgi and green screen but
like i don't think safety wise you could
get away with that i don't think so
either the stuff that we did as kids in
those days i mean i wore a harness in
like my first four or five movies right
i bet
hanging from the train trestle hanging
from the skull and bones thing and and
that was actually another scary that was
a scary goonies moment that spielberg
did shoot where i where the floor drops
out from underneath me and i have to
overwhelm myself back yeah and i have to
throw myself back because you can't just
look like the you know to make it look
like the floor really drops out from
under you you know you can't just like
all of a sudden you know let your feet
drag you have to actually kick them out
to make it look like whoa whoa whoa you
know like the feet the floor just went
away so so you know you're literally
like kicking over the air and then
letting yourself fall and and relying on
this tiny little thin
uh wire that's secured to your belt
strap and then they've got a black belt
around you and then that thing hooks on
to the main thing so so how far off the
ground are you it was about 30 feet up
so i'm about 30 feet up yeah i mean this
is a real really really tall thing like
when you went up to the skull and bones
you know the road the the floor that
came out and all that stuff with the
keyboard and the organ like you had to
go up a windy staircase all the way
around it on the outside of the thing
just to be able to get inside the shell
where the set was
so steven
and i hit it off he takes me to the set
up holder guys we you know i spent a
great day together it was amazing he
fell in love with me and he says okay
here's the deal you're going to star an
e.t it's going to be you and this other
boy named elliot that's the character
and it's the two of you you find this
alien and he tells me the story and i'm
so excited and we make the deal and i
get the movie and i'm in the movie and
then six months goes by
and all of a sudden i get a call from
steven literally on a saturday
at home
during the summer
and he calls me up and he says corey how
are you buddy and i said i'm excited
when are we starting i haven't heard
from you in so long and he says well
i have some very sad news for you
and i said oh no and he says yes
sadly since we last spoke there's been a
major rewrite
and the studio felt that this movie
works better as a family film
than it does is a story of two boys who
are friends
so
okay so they're getting rid of the other
kid right right right so what's the
problem uh yeah so i'm elliott so he's
like no so what we have to do now is
we've taken your part and we've turned
it into a brother and a sister we've
literally split your part into two other
roles which is an older brother
and a younger sister so true really
messed you up drew screwed me up yeah
it's all good
it's all her fault
oh my god no no well you know
it was a blessing i mean look we all
would have loved to get down with e.t we
would have all loved him right right
playing that character or playing in
that movie and having that fun but at
the end of the day but it led to great
things look what happened to henry
thomas
god forbid you know he did this great
performance and then and then he did
like one other movie i don't know what
happened i don't know why but but oh see
i just kind of disappeared oh see i
think he's done
i've seen him in a bunch of things no no
no no no no no no no no no no oh i see
as a kid as a kid as a kid yeah yeah was
shut down after that that's the
interesting thing corey when you think
about like big picture whether that was
like you know when you examine these
things as being good or bad and i hate
to speak in such like general terms but
like
you just said a truth about his career
which is yeah it kind of stalled as a
kid it picked back up and he's done
great work since but but i i wonder if
that then allowed him and i wonder how
you feel about this you could speak to
this better than anyone if that allowed
him to have a more quote unquote normal
life and cultivate probably so yeah you
know what i mean look at sean astin it
certainly worked that way for sean you
know yeah five six years off to joshua
kid josh brolin took years off to be a
normal kid jamison lander a lot of you
know the kids that i grew up with that
that are still friends of mine today uh
yeah had that opportunity i didn't have
that opportunity right right you were
going like non-stop you were going like
one after another so so which is so this
inevitably leads to it so what happened
was once we had that phone call then
stephen said to me i promise you i will
make it up to you
and i promise that i'll put you in my
next film wow and i said okay great well
i'll you know i'll take that to the bank
and cash it you know yeah and i didn't
believe him i didn't think we'd ever
hear from him again and then sure enough
like six months later he calls me up and
he says hey i've got this movie i'm
doing called gremlins and i'd like you
to go in and read for the director
because i'm not directing it but but i'd
like you to read for the director his
name is joe dante and i said great and i
went in and i read for joe and then that
started another great relationship
that's cool joe and i have been friends
forever and we've done like five
projects together so you know i love him
i love cho tanza he's one of another one
of my favorite directors you're gonna
have to hook me up with him oh cause we
love such a sweetheart so we'd love to
have him on oh yeah yeah yeah yeah
when you're getting these calls from
spielberg and you're a kid who has this
now relationship with this guy
do
are you at a regular school
where are you in terms of like you're i
was yeah so how was that very much at a
regular school and i was very much
getting beaten up every day oh because
what because you're the hollywood guy
who's like in this well yeah because
like why do you get to leave early you
know why are you why is your mom always
picking you up and you always get to
leave early and then you don't come for
a week right you disappear for a month
at a time you were different you know
who yeah so they think oh you must think
you're really special right yeah so they
wanted to beat me up for that but you
know but every kid made me profoundly
believe that i was fat and ugly wow
that's awful um obviously but then what
gave you the confidence to be able to be
so
natural and present on screen like how
did you then because that's such a
that's a very vulnerable thing to do is
to be in front of a camera and to be
well like that scene you talked about
instead because i was so well trained
man i mean think about it if you're
doing that since you're three years old
you don't know any different you've got
to be the most charming kid to get those
commercials and to get those jobs when
you're three and so you know my mom
would would stick me in a room and make
me learn songs
and so i would memorize these songs
and then i would go in and i would sing
to them so they would learn that i a i
had good memorization skills
be that i could be outgoing and charming
and see that i could sing as well if
they needed corey
that's so interesting because i've known
some other people in my life who had
been who had a similar path as you were
child actors were successful and i i
always wondered this about them as well
and i see remnants of it of that what
you just described which is to get the
job and in your case
to
have safety to have um a family that you
could count on to go to these jobs and
these sets it meant you had to be
charming you had to be
right it's cute or whatever it was or
funny
are there do you ever find yourself
behaving in a way that you're like you
think ah that's a remnant of that uh
childhood stuff that i'm trying to
ingratiate myself
yeah not anymore yeah yeah anymore but i
think there was you know it's i think
it's called the fake hollywood thing
yeah you know yeah that fake smile we
all put on
right but some people are better than
grades yeah but see some people are
better you know i i know people like
there's a couple people i won't mention
names i know a couple of my soap star
friends yeah you know who are able to
just have that million dollar smile like
all the time and michael jackson was
that way the whole jackson family really
and and i'll sit there and be like dude
like the world's blowing up right now
and you've got this giant grin on your
face and they're like well that's
because fans are watching you know and
i'm like how do you do that how do you
do that that's what fascinates me that's
that exactly that thing and i'm sure
talk about um you know survival
mechanism like michael jackson's [ __ ] he
dealt with in the stat as it turns out
you know the darkness that he was like
contending with fighting fighting yeah
so that must make it um
and now i'm thinking about your mother
and how she's in denial about what she
did like that kind of darkness
maybe that's just a survival mechanism
and and when it's so heightened in
michael jackson's case or in any sort of
famous person's case you just have to
get be better at it i suppose yeah
exactly well and you know and that's the
thing you've got to kind of
create this this image this cookie
cutter yeah kind of facade of what they
want of what's going to make the fans
happy what's going to make the business
happy what's going to make everybody
happy so you forget about what makes you
happy because all you're doing is is
putting on this projection for everybody
else well and so i think that true
happiness comes when you start to
realize that you know you've got to live
your life for you when did you really
confront that that truth because i agree
when i got sober when i was 18 years old
wow wow
so you know going down that path i i
uh you know had a few bad years where i
experimented in drugs not because i
thought about it but because i had a
child molester who was molesting me and
giving me drugs to to to get me messed
up so that he could take advantage oh my
god so um every drug that i ever tried
uh was because he introduced it to me
and told me i should try it oh so this
is that guy but whatever happened to
this guy uh he's still running free he's
still out there oh my god yeah sadly
uh you know we did a documentary we put
out a year ago called my truth where i
exposed all of this stuff uh what was
that whatever happened i don't really
want to go that
no nothing legal there was no legal
problem they stole it they pirated the
film they hacked it they made probably a
hundred million dollars off of the the
the profits and and stole all profits
from us because they literally created a
alternate website with an exact replica
of our website and they were streaming
the movie streaming the movie at ten
dollars more a ticket than we had
actually streamed it for but they stole
our stream preventing our people from
being able to see it the actual ticket
buyers and then they went and sold it
but they also gave it away in in huge
quantities on youtube devaluising the
worth of it yeah um and and then you
know went and sold dvd copies i mean
there was an entire network responsible
for this well uh whatever it was it was
it was a giant operation
along with a disinformation campaign uh
you know with with a whole cult of
people that were terrorizing me on a
daily basis i mean it it got so insane
and so intense that i just had to walk
away you know look at the end of the day
i did what i promised i would do i made
my best friend a promise that i would
tell his story i got the story told uh
and this is important not as many
yeah yeah the point is i i did what i
was supposed to do i kept my promise
that's good and and and you know
hopefully some people learn some things
from it and that's it and and now it's
it's put away because i i just couldn't
deal with the pain of it anyway yeah i
better be honest
you said so for up until you were 18
during that time you weren't going to a
regular school then right once things
started really rolling
oh no no yeah i stopped going to regular
school around 13. okay all right and and
so 13 14 yeah that's when i started
going to private schools and and it only
got worse to be honest the kids at
private school were way brattier than
the kids at regulars oh my god
so interesting to imagine because i grew
up you know in a fairly
relatively very normal suburban
upbringing and
but if i had thought about somebody like
you i would just i'm sure every a lot of
people assume that you had it made in
the shade that you were
you know you're in these movies and
you're getting to do all this exciting
stuff and um i i would never have
considered that uh how how you know dark
some of these elements could have been i
everybody everybody thought that i had
such an easy life that i was kind of
eating off of silver spoons but the
truth of the matter is i've had to work
very very hard for everything that i've
attained in this world yeah and
everything i've achieved and and i
continue to work hard i don't i don't
ever rest on my laurels i don't ever get
comfortable i'm always pushing myself to
do better yeah
to change to grow well not just hustling
but it's more about i mean it used to be
that nowadays it's more about creating
meaningful
art you know things that i'm proud of
and things that things that excite me or
or evoke an emotion yeah you know some
sort of an emotion or or something that
i know that it's going to give me the
palette to get the audience to evoke an
emotion so right now more important
right right now that's music it sounds
like more musical it's everything yeah
it's everything you know i mean look i i
produced the documentary last year we
put that out last year uh and i'd been
doing acting up until last year uh but
after all that i just decided i wanted a
reset yeah and i've literally taken the
last this has been the first time in my
life the last two years that i haven't
started in a film
and it's the first time literally in my
entire life that i've gone two years
without starring in a film are you what
are you what vehicle are you waiting for
i mean what what or are you or or is
that do you harbor ambitions to like i'm
not yeah yeah i'm not i'll tell you what
for me it's about a reset right now yeah
uh i feel like you know i made it
through the first half of my life god
knows how i'm lucky enough to have made
it this part yeah but but but you know
i'm very very lucky in the fact that my
music is like totally like taking off oh
good uh my new single which just you
know came out feeling funny i'm feeling
funny i almost said it premiered there
you go premiered on number uh at number
two on spotify oh cool the day that it
came out you know with like 1500 streams
in one day or something which is pretty
remarkable for a guy that's you know an
independent guy that never had a label
so i finally signed with a record label
oh not the first time ever i mean wow
you know i've been putting them out
under my own label this whole time
sci-fi records uh but i finally signed
with my first record deal at 50 years
old i know it's crazy like nothing like
becoming an overnight sensation after 30
years yeah you know so so we'll just
make sure we talk about the website
where they can find this and uh yeah so
coreyfeldman.net i mean that's my
website but you can follow me on twitter
at corey underscore feldman you can
follow me on the gram
i don't do facebook so much anymore yeah
but i'm on the gram a lot and i'm on
twitter i occasionally see you you i
love when you and jerry jerry o'connell
correspond uh any any time there's a
stand by me thing i love your exchange
whenever you go well we're doing we're
doing a big reunion oh right okay so
that's exciting so i can't believe it's
the 35th anniversary standard
anniversary i want to talk about jerry a
little bit jerry o'connell who is a very
good probably the best friend of the
show jerry calls in a lot we talk to him
a lot he's kind of like i love jerry to
death he's such a sweet guy and it's
funny to imagine the two of you as now
married with these wives and and you
know because again like and kids and
kids and all of it but that movie was so
uh formidable to um uh not now that's
the wrong word uh formative um
during that time in my life that i still
sometimes and i'm sure a lot of people
have this with you they see you as those
characters as those because it's on tv
all the time for whatever the reason
yeah so are people no the weird thing is
yeah i get like you know 12 13 year old
girls hitting me up on instagram saying
i want to marry me oh you know and i'll
be like
i'm
um thank you as do you yeah yeah thanks
well clean living
um but doing that movie you were talking
about that scene uh the junkyard that
was one of so many scenes that felt so
real it felt so like you really were
these kids living this experience
looking for that body and it was a big
challenge yeah that scene was a big
challenge for me and it was very
difficult for me because i had to cry
yeah on camera and that was the first
time that i'd been asked to cry on
camera other than the time when i was on
friday the 13th and jason
literally lifted me through the air and
it like totally surprised me because
they lied to me and they did not tell me
that he was gonna be coming well they
told me he was gonna be coming but they
gave me a different timing and the way
they counted it it was like on three you
know and then i waited till three and
nothing happened and they did that on
purpose and they got this sheer horror
and terror on my face which literally
probably uh uh you know affected me for
years oh my god i was traumatized i know
i hear stories like that corey and i
think well on the one hand because i
just directed this movie so i i'm i'm
very
into the idea of of doing things like
that not not not with kids but but you
know doing what you need to do to get a
performance to get a natural performance
but when it comes to kids i don't know i
that that to me is uh it feels a little
wrong it feels a little wrong to play
with their emotional i know i know but
that said but rob reiner didn't do that
no rob reiner did not that was a
completely different director and i'm
not going to call him out but for fans
of the franchise they already know i
know okay um yes but no no rob reiner
didn't do anything like that and and and
you know good on him but he was
he really knew how to talk to the kids i
mean he was really really very good
at relating to us and getting on our
level and the way that he he gained that
trust was because we did a series of
rehearsals prior to the film's beginning
where we spent two weeks
in a hotel room just rob in the four
boys oh yeah cherries and we would play
these games and it was like you know
kind of acting workshop games i guess
because i've never been to acting
workshops because
the boys told me you know oh yeah we do
this stuff in acting class
um
but it was like a you know mirror game
where we would like have to mirror each
other's reactions or
you know a game where somebody would say
something at this level and we'd have to
go up the next level and then up the
next level simple acting games
right exactly yeah so we did that kind
of stuff and then we played regular
games and you know football and we went
river rafting and
we did all this great fun stuff that
boys would want to do together in the
middle of a summer break and cory was it
like was it immediate with those with
those other three were you because i
know you discussed your home life and
how it must have been i'm imagining it
was like a real
saving grace that they're getting to
have this experience with did you just
it was in a way i mean look that was my
first time also away from my my mother
on a set for a long period of time
because my mother originally came with
me
uh up to do stand by me
and then um kind of like what happened
on lost boys where she kind of had a
meltdown after a few weeks and she said
i can't do this anymore i'm i'm out of
here i'm gonna get you a set sitter so
she hired a local woman to be my set
sitter who was a wonderful woman very
sweet lady and i loved her especially
because i could run amok and manipulate
the hell out of her and she was too
afraid to say no to me so
wow it worked out very well if she's
listening uh thank you sorry sorry for
all that yes yes
and he remembers
making my amends making my amen
and that's the thing is that you know a
lot of people don't realize a lot of
people hold me accountable right for
actions that i took when i was on
goonies or actions that i took when i
was on stamping i mean i remember having
a talk with uh martha plimpton where you
know she had been complaining about me
to you know various interviews saying
well corey was such a brat and we fought
and i'm like i'm like martha just you
know i'm sorry yeah i was just a kid
yeah i didn't know any better you know
and no she was very gracious very
gracious no i love her today but will
whedon on the other hand uh had been
holding apparently some grudge against
me from stand by me
for all these years that i was not even
aware of what and when we got together
10 years ago for the 25th anniversary
this is a true story and it was all of
us and it was me and and jerry and will
and rob and richard dreyfuss was even
there and we were all doing this thing
for abc news and we take a break for
five minutes and we'll also think you
know you got a minute and i said sure
and we go into the corner and he says
listen i just wanted to bring something
up that's kind of stuck with me for all
these years but there was this day where
you you know remember the leech scene
and we got into this fight and you were
like being a total dick and you i you
know wow whatever i did i you know i
whether i smacked him or i said
something and he smacked me or i don't
know but we got into some kind of
physical altercation and i remember rob
you know was so mad at us like stop it
stop it and then he was finally like you
know what screw it just shoot just shoot
get it get it oh they filmed it and yes
they filmed it because that tension and
that anger in that scene where we're all
piling on top of each other
and then it all breaks with laughter
right yeah it starts off where we're
fighting and then it breaks with
laughter and a lot of those moments were
actually captured from the realness of
that moment of fighting but i didn't
remember it all you know it was all part
of a wash for me and so will pulls me
aside he goes you know you said some
things or you did whatever it was i
don't know what he was hurting i was so
upset about but he was hurt yeah and i
said you know will i'm really sorry
uh you know just so you know i was an
abused kid so a lot of the things i did
i'm sure were acting out in spite
because you know
i was messed up but you know but please
don't hold it against me you know yeah
yeah kid man
i changed a lot
and and i'm sure
i'm sure he immediately forgave
yeah yeah yeah
he still holds the chip well everybody
well you don't find out
but you know what's cool about that is
that he did that um well a that he did
that privately that he pulled you aside
you know and that um
and that he did it at all that he
expressed himself and that he gave you
the chance to you know
make amends yeah and and you know what
it's good like i i would rather clear
those kinds of things oh my god me too
the last thing i ever want is somebody
out there having a misconception
or or thinking that i'm just holding on
to something you know
yeah or something i did cause somebody
pain enough for them to to be affected
in their life today i mean that that
would make me feel terrible of course
you understand that because on a much
larger scale it's an effect what you did
with your mother that you gave her the
opportunity you know to address these
things that you you were wrong you're
the wrongs that she committed against
you
it's about healing
it's about healing and we've all got to
heal we've got to heal from the scars of
our past right at the end of the day
that the best way to do that is to let
go with forgiveness and love you know
but also to to sometimes we have to walk
through it sometimes we've got to really
get it sometimes we've got to you know
bring those uncomfortable moments back
up so that we can uncover discover and
discard that's the way i look at it life
could be a dream sweetheart
[Music]
in the early 2000s millions of
households across the world tuned in to
watch contestants battle for the last
rose or to be the final survivor on the
island reality tv was beginning to
dominate the airwaves and every show
needed to be bigger flashier more
scandalous than the last but in the case
of one infamous dating show the real
drama was happening off-screen and it
would shape the future of reality tv the
reality tv series there's something
about miriam seemed like a pretty
standard dating competition six young
men vied for the affection of miriam
rivera a beautiful model from mexico but
when miriam revealed that she was a
trans woman during the show's finale the
on-screen drama sparked an international
uproar about gender sexuality and
whether reality television had finally
gone too far follow harsh reality the
story of miriam rivera on apple podcast
amazon music or you can listen early and
add free by joining wonder plus in apple
podcasts or the wondery app
[Music]
[Music]
what was river like cory how important
was he in your life oh he was such a
great guy well we were friends before
that we had known each other prior to
the movie we were up for all the same
parts we were always reading against
each other
and we didn't see each other as
competition because we got along so well
so i always knew if river was there we
were going to have fun on the audition
or while we were waiting so because he
would bring a football if they'd pull up
with their van you know and there would
be like five kids in his family because
it was like yeah they were like
troubadours so they'd like they'd roll
up with their van and they'd open the
sliding door and they'd come out with
the football and they'd be running
around the parking lot playing ball
while everybody else is sitting there
with their sides waiting to read you
know and i'd be out there tossing the
football with them right so
uh so him and i always got along on that
level and then i remember the day when
we were on the plane
heading up to oregon and it was this
little prop lane and river and i sat
next to each other the whole trip
and we were both scared out of our minds
because the plane was hitting like some
massive turbulence and it was just
shaking all over the place
dropping 500 feet at a time and that
kind of stuff and we were terrified
and uh
you know i just remember us kind of like
teasing each other and laughing and you
know we kept each other sane through it
we definitely kept each other safe
but we were together almost every night
for the first month until his family
separated us by going and getting a
house out in the
in the middle of the woods somewhere
they decided they wanted a family ranch
style house to to live at so they took
him out of the hotel but while he was in
the hotel with us oh my god we had so
much fun you know running around
throwing stink bombs and just just doing
what kids do being mischievous we were
so mischievous oh my god corey you talk
about that scene where you had to cry
and another indelible moment in that
movie for me is when
river has to cry i mean he he does cry
when he's talking about the lunch money
i was sitting there watching him really
and yes there was a tinge of jealousy
like how the hell is he able to do that
so well i tried he really cried he
started it off he got the crystals i
remember in the beginning but yeah you
got to realize you're doing those takes
50 times oh take it yeah yeah yeah
it's like in the be like those tight
close-up shots though those were
absolutely authentic and that's when i i
mean i it was like i gained so much
respect for him as an actor sitting on
the set watching him do that i was just
there's only two times in my life i felt
that way that was it was watching river
do that performance right there and
watching corey haim during blown away
there was a scene that he did in this
movie we had called blown away where he
was just like yeah he was so old
exactly he was so on and he was so
focused and i was just like look at you
go man look at you
oh i love it yeah so
yeah you know there's those moments
where you see your friend and you're
proud of them and you're just like yeah
you were
so much better than i even knew you know
i always knew you were good but now i
like now i'm a fan like you know what
what you mentioned in the close-ups you
really that was really him going would
rob reiner start in those scenes would
he start in the close-ups and then pull
back oh okay okay that makes sense yeah
and and and because you don't want to
run it 50 times and get it old right i
mean so i remember him sitting there
with river by that tree stump like the
two of them just sat and talked for
probably a good 30 minutes before they
started recording so i mean he really
got him in the headspace he really got
it yeah yeah yeah we've talked a lot
about the adults around you that have
failed you and ultimately obviously
they're to blame but do you ever have do
you have regrets do you look back and
think uh i wish i'd done such and such
differently well of course i mean
there's so many
great jobs that i lost out on
as a result of my stupid mistakes
you know
um and and you know i can't blame myself
i was a kid who was being handed drugs
by pedophiles to to molest me so it's
not like i was some bad kid i wasn't a
bad kid i was an abused kid who who
unfortunately went down a very wrong
road and that wrong road
you know culminated in this kind of
epitaph of disaster
with with you know um
me being arrested and all this stuff
that happened and and at that point
people just said oh we're not going to
take them seriously you know i was like
they just started like writing me off as
if i like somehow because i had gone
down a dark path and had a bad year now
suddenly my talent was gone and i was no
longer a viable commodity and it's like
whoa wait what so there were things like
i had read for titanic i had read for
you know lord of the rings uh you know
there's a lot of roles where it was very
very close
scent of a woman that was when i oh i
could kill myself but i was such
interested in the al pacino part yes no
not to play el pacino's part to play the
kids
how old do you think i am i'm not that
i'm kidding i'm kidding
no that must have been a yeah i know i
because there were a few of those like
when you uh like star making like you
know it's going to be a huge thing
before it even gets shot you know like
those those scripts and you do regret
those but at the end of the day
i don't regret my life because i'm a
very happy man right now i have a
beautiful family i have a beautiful wife
i have a beautiful son
you know all the stuff that you really
want right you just want love you want a
family you want something secure and
normal in your life some stability and i
have that and and i'm able to create art
and i'm able to do it because i love
doing it you know we're putting out the
box that we're putting out the new album
we're putting out the nfts we're going
to be putting out lots of videos i'm
going to be going on tour
and
who knows if i ever will do another
movie i don't know well i hope you do
because as i said i i'm such a fan of
yours i thought you know so much of what
you did was again just a huge huge part
of all of our childhoods we have a
lightning round we have like a quick
okay uh short question lightning round
just like first thing that comes to mind
um if you'll indulge us okay what is
your most commonly used emoji uh heart
with the kiss oh yeah that's it i think
that's mine too you mean the the blowing
kissing the heart yeah blowing the
kisses
and maybe the heart and the hand the
class jams i kind of use them all in one
oh me too yeah good yeah
if you could be a professional athlete
what sport would you play well i've kind
of done a bit of it you know i mean i
did i did play some uh ice hockey
i did play baseball for bad news bears
for two years you know uh oh no kidding
so i mean i've kind of and then i've
done like karate movies where you got to
compete and you got to learn all the
stuff you know so it's kind of like when
you're an actor you know how it is you
do a lot of stuff you know so i don't
play a lot of athletic roles you don't
have really is that true i don't play
uh i don't know why yeah not because
you're against it or anything no no in
fact i i would love that that'd be fun
it'd be fun to learn a skill like that
an athletic skill i think too i had to
learn karate to do like a kickboxing
movie i had to learn some really good
kickboxing stuff which i started
learning when i was really really young
but
um i mean i've never played in a
football movie what was the movie that
aside from your own that you really
wanted to introduce your son to when he
was growing up oh star wars huge star
wars fan i always wanted that's that's
one of my probably only regrets is that
i never got to be a part of star wars i
always wanted to go to that movie yeah
you were just kind of starting out right
when it was being made no yeah no no i
it was way before my time you could have
played a jawa yeah right
maybe i could have played an ewok and
like you know return of the jedi or
something but no i mean i kind of missed
i i guess during return of the jedi that
would have been the time i could have
done it but there was no kids in the
movies so there was no performance uh
but but i'm saying more in the in the
sequels you know i would have oh yeah
yeah yeah i really wanted to be you know
on one of those sequels and i i was just
destroyed that i didn't get to so i
think well they're still making them
let's put it out there does it matter
though does it matter is it really star
wars anymore
can we be real i don't know i love the
mandalorian i was i did really i loved
it with all that all that great acting
and stuff man yeah
i love i i love this all right what what
about your go-to karaoke song you go to
a karaoke club what do you sing uh
jeez
father figure george michael
oh okay that's a good one uh
um and who was your first celebrity
crush drew barrymore duh okay oh funny
okay so i was hurt for a celebrity crush
that's right yes and she
she hit me up through spielberg she
actually called because you know she was
very close yeah she was yeah so yeah as
well yeah more closer than i was and she
was like a daughter to him and uh and so
you know she called amblin and said you
know i think this guy who plays mouth is
really cute and i want to meet him so we
get a call one day from amblin saying
you know would it be okay if we gave
drew barrymore and her mom your your
private phone number and i said sure of
course
what does the cute kid from e.t want
with me and she's like oh she's she's
got a crush on you and it's puppy love
and i was like oh that's cute but i mean
come on i'm 11. she's like six or seven
yeah
that's a much younger lady it's a may
december a little weird situation a
little weird so we went out on one
puppy date that we're like you know the
mom picked me up and took us to the
movies oh and we went and watched a
movie together and that was for what did
you see what you go to see i don't
remember probably like short circuit or
something some 80s movie right yeah
um maybe zapped i don't know um so
and then so we went on that first date
we stayed friends
and kind of you know saw each other
through the years and then we ended up
doing a movie together called 15 and
getting straight
which was an abc tv movie of the week
thing we started with tatum o'neil
about kids that were going through drug
problems trying to get their lives isn't
that funny and you've all gone through
it right well she was going through it
at the time tatum had already gone
through it and i was still virginal i
hadn't even gotten into my drug problem
yet oh my god and i was just going off
the deep end there
actually when uh when when i did the
movie so i was actually a bit
hypocritical there uh doing this
anti-drug
right yes there you go we'll go with
method um
so so anyway uh yeah so at that point i
was
17 andrew was like
14 turning 15. and so right when she
turned 15 we started dating and that and
that's that's when we dated for real and
we dated for about three months oh my
god that's funny isn't that funny and
was that just like
uh a [ __ ] show with the pop you
mentioned the paparazzi it must have
been crazy the two of you together
but there was no paparazzi like that
that's a thing there was no tmz there
was no internet there was no websites
there was none of that stuff so yeah i
mean literally you know if you were kids
you weren't going out to clubs so you
didn't run into them
um so the only time we would you know do
press stuff was we'd go to the academy
awards together or we went to the
director's guild awards and we presented
steven spielberg with a with an award
together so you know it was more of them
using us as opportunities for hollywood
glamour type thing you know like hey
look at here's two spielberg kids
together yeah two cute kids yeah yeah
yeah yeah there's a lot more of that
stuff that's really funny uh if you had
to get another tattoo what what would it
be and where would you get it
i don't think i ever will oh really yeah
you have to have two you've done it i
have a half sleeve on both arms but okay
one is for my son and for corey um
so they're both in there it's actually
uh
it was designed in my in my mind
just a few few weeks before uh haim
passed and i i woke up and i saw this
vision of this
and because he he loved tattoos he loved
art and so i had a fix i wanted to do
because it was like i had my ex-wife and
then an ex-fiance on each arm so i had
to do cover-ups and so i had thought of
this great idea for a cover-up
and i told i got all excited and i woke
up and i called corey and i said man i
got this idea for this tattoo and i
explained the whole thing to him i want
to use my kids eyes because if i'm never
going to put anything on my body again
it's got to be something that i know i
would want to last forever and i'll
never forget it and i'll never regret it
and that would be my kid
so that's what i did i put my kids eyes
and my kid's name on my arm and i
explained to him how this vision i had
for doing it and he says to me well
where am i in there
i said what do you mean
and he goes well i'm his godfather right
i said yeah and he goes well if you're
going to have the heavens and you're
going to have you know his eyes looking
up at the heavens then shouldn't you put
me in the heavens looking down on him oh
weird wow and i was like well that's a
little egotistical man like you know i
don't know i'll think about it bro you
know
and then like he died like like a month
later
and then of course i ended up putting
two two two
for him
in the tattoo because he called it you
know wow wow that's yeah that's crazy
that's really beautiful um and what is
your favorite sorry to switch gears in
such a trivial way but what is your
favorite fruit
i love fruit you know my wife's a
fruitarian does that mean she only eats
fruit it means she mostly eats fruit
like that's the basis of her diet yeah
she starts every day off with fresh
fruit she drinks like lemon water to
start her day and then she'll have some
celery juice she does the celery juice
and then she does like a fruit bowl or a
fruit smoothie or a heavy metal detox
smoothie or whatever she's got these
different smoothies she does but like
yeah but it's all based in fruit and
it's like bananas and wild blueberries
wild blueberries are like the magic
fruit that everybody needs to eat it's
like cleans out your liver antioxidants
it's crazy it's a crazy magical
fruit that exists on this planet that we
should all be eating it's a soup what's
it called
wild blueberries wild blueberries oh my
god it's so funny corey i've been eating
a lot of those i live
that's great that's great really wild
blueberries okay let me tell you if you
if you get covered wild blueberries
every day is a great way to defend
yourself against it also the celery
juice celery juice regiment uh i do the
celery juice every day
i mean she's got me into all this very
kind of i gotta say you look incredible
for i you said you were 50 yeah what 75
aren't you for 70 yeah now you look for
mel gibson's age
um who is who would you want to play you
in your biopic cory oh god we already
did one
and uh they were great those kids were
really oh really yeah they did the the
two quarries movie on a lifetime or
whatever uh oh so you got your pro oh i
don't i don't know who played you but um
oh they were great kids they were very
talented super good no i don't know man
if we ever did a real one
um
i don't know
who would you want to play me um i would
like to see i'm trying to i would like
to see sam
sam rockwell maybe play you
uh isn't he too old
uh maybe he's well he's 53
52. you'd need somebody that was like in
their 20s yeah that's true that's true
maybe like miles teller or somebody um
yeah uh timothy chalamet can do anything
yeah i mean uh who's your favorite
muppet who is your favorite muppet
growing up
animal
okay
yeah it's good i always like yoda as
well i mean i don't know if yoda counts
as a muppet but yoda does yeah i think
so muppet i am not
and did you i bet i bet you got to
fraternize with those characters
uh well
no
i didn't really get much muppet time i
did you know a tv series with madame
from you know wayland flowers and madam
you remember that puppet so i did do a
tv series with a puppet which was i'm
kidding
and you know we got the gremlins puppets
and you know all that oh my god i i
really never slipped into the henson
world too much which was sad i really
wanted to do sesame street yeah i really
wanted to do the [ __ ] like i was
doing it i know right yeah yeah i don't
know how it missed all that but it's not
too late it is not too late
um oh it's funny i as you began that i i
was thinking of the gremlins theme song
which is also so good uh
do you prefer dogs or cats corey i
prefer all animals okay good answer
that's the right answer i'm a i'm i'm
i'm an animal rights guy i'm uh
you know i work with peta i work with
peta well no i'll smack this mosquito i
have to but they're bloodsucking you
know me and bloodsuckers i know but
they're just they're biological
imperative uh what about the beatles or
the rolling stones if you have to pick
one beetles all day and i love i love
the stones i love mick i'm always very
inspired by their longevity and their
stick-to-itiveness uh but that said
they're nobody nobody can sing rock and
roll like paul mccartney paul mccartney
has the best rock and roll voice in
history i agree if you could if you were
out somewhere at a jukebox
uh you put in a couple beatles songs
what do you immediately go to right now
i mean
it depends on the day you know i could
be saying like in your in this state
you're in right now like what do you
want to hear maybe mother nature's son
and and and helter skelter you know i
mean yeah oh how different so right
that's those are perfect examples of
like a same album of the the the
dichotomy the dichotomy
well yeah but i just how versatile they
were right
but that's how expansive that catalog
and just paul man if you listen to those
early takes i don't know if you've heard
the white album outtakes but it's just
brilliant dude and you listen to like he
does this take on why don't we do it on
the road all right why aren't we doing
the road uh which i actually played on
my last tour i played drums and sang
that one which is a lot of fun uh but
but the thing is is like you know he's
doing like the the album version it's
all growl and it's like well don't we do
it in the road you know
but like you listen to this outtake
version and he did it really soft and
pretty he's like why don't we do it in
the row
you know and you're like
whoa that's a different choice and you
listen to him do that perfectly like
flawlessly no for note you know just
like so classy so clean and then second
verse he switches into the growl and he
does that with like this flamboyant just
boldness and you're just like jesus man
yeah you're just perfect like every
inflection you never make a mistake oh
well you got to see the um on hulu
there's a great uh series where he's
just going through with rick rubin he's
going through all of his songs how he
came to write them uh yeah just him i've
seen some glimpses of it i haven't
actually watched it oh you'll love it
it's good
it's so good it's so funny i'm looking
forward to getting back man i can't wait
for the new peter jackson to get back
i never understood uh why don't we do it
in the road they say no one will be
watching us right no one will be
watching us
if you do it in the road i'm sure
there's a chance somebody might watch
right
odds are pretty good that's something
he's going to eventually stop
well either that or maybe you just don't
look so hot doing it and that's kind of
that's true so no one will want to watch
nobody wants to see this
nothing is here sweaty on the side of
the road right um do you prefer seinfeld
or friends
i am i'm not a tv guy
okay uh ketchup or mustard
ketchup ketchup all the way um corey
i've just so taken advantage of your
time and and i'm sorry if i've uh i kept
you first no it's fine it's been fun
it's been fun i've been sad that we've
been able to do this me too i really
appreciate you hanging in there with all
of this and um once again like i it i'm
so glad i get to tell you sort of in
person
how much your work is meant to me and i
know so many people listening i
appreciate that very much and thank you
for being such a gracious host and thank
you for all the years of great work as
well enjoy your day man god bless you
and thank you thanks corey all right
brother peace peace
so that happens
it's a little like um he's got it's the
same it's weird it's like i've always
same i had the same
thought
to uh fred savage it's like i know that
voice i know is is just so part of my
any
consciousness what is it how is it how
does it go
it's almost like he's running out of
breath all the time yes yes yeah
but it's a very recognizable you're
right it is like unmistakable teddy
duchamp yep if i heard that anywhere in
in a grocery store i it would be
unmistakable yeah iconic and i was
thinking like when he was talking about
potentially acting again and
great directors how they can resurrect
careers really give people another shot
directors like
darren aronofsky the way he did with
mickey rourke and and the way he's going
to do with brenda frazier i know um
tarantino with john travolta in
perfection oh yeah it takes like a real
like auteur like some powerful filmmaker
it'd be cool to see that happen to corey
feldman yeah i would because he he was
so good really good so good he talks
about uh river phoenix and stand by me
but
god he was great in that movie i know
and as was corey haim and um people
forget that you know because of corey
hayne was and lucas was amazing really
incredible and um
he was he referenced a scene that he
didn't blown away which that was really
funny but i knew you i know you're going
to say i know what you're going to say
that
right away like oh yeah blow it away
nicole eggert
a little horn ball i was 16 why no no i
know i know and it's what i how i
remember that movie i don't think i
don't think you're allowed to be
a 16 year old anymore but but i think i
think
lust as a 16 year old may have been
canceled what does 16 year olds do now
how do they put a lid on them
god knows uh i'm glad he didn't dwell on
that um but he
he did mention corey heyman like it
brings to mind all those great
performances of corey feldman's in the
80s people don't think of him because of
his troubles and how public his troubles
were people kind of forget what a great
actor he was see i was a little
obviously still am a little younger than
you
so those movies in the 80s i didn't see
them until the 90s so my memory of corey
feldman when i was a kid
was more like the uh license to drive
like post 80s when he was where he was
like the two cory's yeah like that was
my memory he had that like big hair yeah
like the earrings and like yeah i
obviously i love those movies but i
didn't see them
like you did when they came out oh yes
so like his like those all those movies
he did with corey heym those like that's
what you remember yeah oh funny yeah he
started doing
now like straight to video doesn't
really mean anything when you say like a
straight to video movie like so many
most movies now like even bigger budget
are essentially so but back then it was
it was said kind of pejoratively like so
he started doing a lot of those in the
90s how would you say i'm trying to
think of another way to say like um
exploitation like cinematics like late
night cinemax like from the yeah late
90s those kinds of movies some of those
corey
movies would qualify as like i think a
cinema like late nights you don't want
to say skin of max right i don't want to
say skin i know but anyway yeah
he was one of those and how do you ask
somebody that like why did you do this
well he alluded to it a little bit he
said
when he had that
fall when he got into trouble and he
went down i think as he said a bad path
yeah
that he lost credibility in the industry
and people
um despite his
acting prowess he lost um status well he
was seen as problematic in hollywood you
know it was something that happened to
drew but she was in a similar boat as
corey feldman in in the 90s where she
was so famous that's part of the problem
was that he had gotten so famous people
don't
may not remember that that he was like a
huge star
and a lot of those and he would go out
and he was a teenager and so a lot of
those problems that he was dealing with
he was like a tabloid
guy
and so that kind of overshadowed
his acting i think well it's also people
like aren't certain actors hard to
ensure like yeah um i wonder if robert
downey jr became almost impossible yeah
and and then obviously iron man changed
everything for him but for years he was
in that position right you know he
couldn't get work to the point where
even when he did iron man they had to
have all of these there had to be all
these like stipulations about the
insurance like it was still hard to get
him to get him insured on that like he
he had to have gone through a lot of
programs and stuff but yeah you're right
like maybe it was the same god it's so
interesting because then you think if
corey feldman hadn't
pivoted
to doing these movies that we're talking
about
you know whatever you want to call them
skinnymax movies and done like certain
reality shows
he started doing kind of more outlandish
things
um and i wonder if he hadn't done that i
know if he
would have been better positioned to
have a big comeback because he is so
good yeah i know maybe probably and not
that not to say it's he can't still have
it but i think but it would take a
really take a lot
well and it would also take a direct
release there are a handful of directors
who have that power to do that who can
do that and also the like a real
visionary who can get past like whatever
his
the optics of someone like cory i'm sure
people will look at this episode and be
like corey fell and have make some
conclusions about him i mean i know i
did yeah
there was obviously part of me that was
like oh it would be so exciting to have
him on the show
he's a great actor yeah i'm so part of
our youth but there is another part of i
know if i'm being honest that was like
uh he might be a little tough to talk to
when he's kind of gotten a little
yeah
i was really really surprised by how
intelligent and me too grounded he
sounded and like sensitive and
thoughtful i was like very impressed
with him me too i really enjoyed talking
to him i know i had preconceived notions
too and i it was based on whatever
interview i had seen him do and talk
show and i i think there was a part of
him that always seemed to me just as an
outsider having seen him in like pop
culture always seemed a little
untethered yeah like he was struggling
and when i talked to him it felt now to
haven't had that conversation he really
felt like he had done a lot of work
and he seemed very comfortable with
himself and there's also a natural charm
that anyone who's that successful as a
kid
i would suspect that there's a certain
charm and
likability yeah that you never that
never fully goes away you know he still
has there's a reason that he became so
big in the first place he has a certain
yeah charm about him and i was trying to
get at that i didn't quite know how to
ask that about
that child actor thing that was like
that precociousness the remnants of
which sometimes last like i've known
child actors who grow up and they have
this
hey there you know some do some when
charming people is a part of your
upbringing it's about their lives yeah
their lives are so interesting to think
about that's all he knew since he was a
little little kid so it was
second nature to him
that was really heartbreaking about his
oh my god i mean holy [ __ ] i know that
stuff so casually that stuff is so i
mean there was part of me that was
really bummed that we didn't get to hear
that first half of the interview yeah
even though his recap was very
impressive but there was another part of
me that was kind of relieved because
it's so hard to hear that stuff it's so
hard to know about kids being neglected
and abused like that especially when you
can get such a clear visual because of
course you know what he looked like
sounded like you know what he was like
as a kid
and that character i kept thinking about
his character in standby i know i was
too you know both everything about teddy
duchamp
i couldn't help but think god he must
have channeled that pain in his real
life pain during that scene okay
i'm glad you brought that up because
that's what i would have thought too um
cory feldman would have channeled his
actual pain to deliver an impressive
performance in the church here at scene
and stand by me um did you ask him that
i did and and so this was in the first
interview and because we talked about
because i said i think we even i even
started by
talking about it's one of the most
impressive scenes in any movie like that
and the
we reference later the river phoenix the
lunch money scene with will wheaton but
um because they did so many takes he had
to kind of use the uh menthol there's a
way where you menthol but once he did
once it got in there and this is kind of
like this is the idea behind those
menthol chris they call the crystals
where like a makeup lady would or man or
person uh-oh we'll just
we'll just blow
these menthol crystals into your eyes
and it causes them to water and whatever
and
i've always prided myself on i may have
used them once but i pride myself on not
you know but sometimes they help
jump-start the tears and sometimes you
need them after like several takes but
he kind of
alluded to using those and i said
well and and he in fact said he didn't
have that
connection to his
yes he had a very difficult
like father figure and and but he hadn't
um a kid he hadn't reconciled himself
through it no no he too oh that makes
sense to the point where he couldn't use
it to like get
in a sec couldn't directly connect his
abusive father or negligent father to
teddy duchess right that makes sense he
does it's almost like when he was acting
that was acting when he was at home that
was him at home that's what he said yeah
that does make sense he was not able to
really you know connect the two wow
that's so interesting but but he did so
it makes it in a way kind of more
impressive that he was able to bring
that performance
but i was thinking about like um how
troublesome had the fine line between
like a genuinely good kid performance
and and then
a potentially abusive way to get them
there which is which he references in
friday the 13th well he did but then i
thought that was interesting that he
also said about stand by me that rob
reiner he's like oh rob reiner wouldn't
do that
that's right he said well [ __ ] just
use it
yeah i know i mean he didn't like he
didn't push them there exactly he didn't
instigate the fight he just he just
rolled the camera it reminds me of that
moment in apocalypse now when francis
ford coppola like
i mean this is a little different
because martin sheen was going through
having a breakdown and
coppola i think
didn't encourage him to drink but like
didn't discourage it and and kept the
cameras rolling after he cut himself i
mean there's a famous scene with
bleeding but to do that to a kid i don't
know i'm like there was a part of me
like i said to him having since we
directed that thing there's a part of me
my director brain is like [ __ ] whatever
get you know however you get the shirts
um but with a kid it's like
yeah it's so weird to panic it's so
weird to picture
uh like behind the scenes bts of a movie
like i know stand by me because it's
it's
so um like etched in my brain as
like that i know so like those
characters saying anything else to each
other or like tossing a football around
or like getting pissed off with each
other i know it's so bizarre it's like
no that didn't happen i know what
happened was what i know happened well
which is why it was so comforting to
hear about that story about will wheaton
yeah how they reconciled and i really
was so nice and i love stories i love me
you know people never love
reconciliation stories
but i really do they're so nice
i love when people forgive each other i
do too it is really
it's because it's writ because the older
you get though oh yeah also not to be
sexist but especially when men do it
because men have a harder time
uh opening up about their feelings yes i
agree you know what else i liked about
it is that will wheaton did it
privately
yes you know that today everything is so
[ __ ] public and you gotta like
everyone airs their [ __ ] and gnarks on
one another like publicly that to go
there's something pure and well now
we're talking about it publicly i know
but like we're talking about a private
event we're talking about how we like
the privacy of it we're publicly talking
about how much we love privacy
that's true what does that mean
we're hypocrites uh no no because i
wouldn't if i had an issue with somebody
no i know i know it's different yeah his
story in general is like such a story of
survival and
yeah granted he hasn't been a celebrated
actor since the 80s at this point but
the fact that he's like he said he has a
family he's doing art that he's proud of
he's doing music that he loves
i love that it's remarkable that he's
been able to
survive i know um let's read a letter
yeah subject
from khari
so two ways two ways okay so probably
just kari
kar why are you saying like that well
it's two ways it's probably kari that
would be one a car
all right we should ask her subject long
drive with life is short dear justin and
christian about a month ago my husband
two cats and one dog and i relocated her
husband's not two cats
i got that yeah about a month ago my
husband two cats and one dog and i
relocated from northern virginia to
portland oregon
lucky i love portland oregon me too
that's a great song that loretta lynn
signed well portland oregon and slogan
fizz if that ain't heav and then tell me
what is i don't know that
uh i'm sure it sounds just like that
back to the letter
we accomplished this via an rv aka eagle
five
and a u-haul truck towing our car so my
husband and i each drove the entire way
2973 miles to be exact wow
i drove the u-haul with our 13-year-old
rescue chihuahua carmen carmen and i
quickly tired of my itunes collection so
i tuned into your podcast nice kari
what a great way to pass the miles and
days in this cross-country drive i have
no idea what order siri played the
episodes in but i found myself
enthralled with all of your guests ah
that's so nice i laughed and cried and
went huh more than a few times
it's nice to elicit a huh yeah it's
almost better than a laugh yeah huh
carmen was a bit indifferent well yeah
the dog the cat i think a chihuahua dog
yeah i thought it was i hope it was more
than a bit indifferent
i hope it was like oh like the way
werner herzeg said that uh over
overwhelming when i looked into the eyes
of the bear i saw overwhelming
best line
oh yeah i hope carmen was overwhelmingly
indifferent
but she is a crotchety old woman now
when we stopped for the day i would give
my husband a rundown of the episodes i
had listened to
it's nice of you kari uh back to kari
thank you for waiting yeah if he did
love it he probably would just listen to
the episodes on his own that is true if
he was that interested he was like all
right then
she'd be like well you know you can hear
it yeah in your car and you're we're
driving to the same place
um
thank you back to cari thank you for
making one of the most stressful times
of my life
our lives just a bit easier your banter
and guest truly helped me relax in this
huge episode of my life that is until
the usb port in the u-haul crapped out
and i had to switch to local radio
thanks again kari carpenter harry
carpenter yes what a great name i know
very alliterative kari and carpenter
with uh three a's
and with a k or a c now c 99 chance that
justin has mispronounced my first name
what does that mean what is it what is
it then it's probably not car
it's probably kari oh that's what she
meant it must have meant car she
probably knew you'd hold the a too long
as well why have the x-ray i don't know
ps would you rather have a sailboat or
an rv as your home
we are currently living in our rv while
we shop for a home in our new state i
have
fantasized about living in both you do
live in an artist i have an rv and then
i love living in but but full-time i
mean as as your home i think i'd rather
be on land i think so too i i
have more
faith in my survival skills on land than
on the water why are you laughing well
i'm picturing trying me's trying to
survive in a boat no but i was just
imagining mick our neighbor in
massachusetts hearing this and like
hearing you say like i i have a little
bit more faith in myself get out of here
a little bit more he doesn't have
survival skills anywhere
he wouldn't know what to do on land or
water
kari
so it's just kari carpenter what a great
name and thank you sounds like karen
carpenter anyway thank you gary and
thanks for your husband for listening to
these episodes secondhand yes recaps
thank you for that letter kari i hope
you liked the corey feldman i i'm glad
that we had him on kari and corey yeah
oh great
and so if you carry about stuff like
that uh that's uh that's a cool way to
end the episode
thank you all for listening
oh yeah thank you to corey and takari
and um the iconic
feldman he is so yeah truly we're
really lucky to have talked to him and a
surreal moment for me and and check out
his stuff uh coreyfeldman.net
and i hope you check it out and that's
it we'll talk to you next week all right
life could be a dream
life could be a dream
[Music]
life is short is hosted by me justin
long it is co-hosted and produced
co-produced by you christian long also
produced by
megan the monaco and katie v allen
senior producer on this one michelle
and the audio engineer is sergio
enriquez executive producer marshall
louis for
wondering
[Music]
i don't know why you don't wear that
where am i going to wear a mugsy booster
like i i don't know you know in
otis and big pond that's a better
question
i might not fit oh maybe i will i had
when i was a kid wait maybe i will
you may be what can i
get out of here you're not gonna do that
you